this is a very large outbreak this is
dr. bill Schaffner I'm an infectious
disease specialist and public health
person coronaviruses are a whole family
of viruses for the most part they don't
cause any real clinical illness except
the occasional cold but you know from
time to time there's a rogue corona
virus that develops we remember SARS
2002 2003 and then there was another the
MERS virus the Middle East respiratory
syndrome virus this new virus like those
other rogue viruses probably was first
transmitted to humans from animals so
the symptoms resemble influenza it's a
respiratory virus initially and so you
have fever not feeling we're very well
coughed and just feeling poorly
we don't have a direct anti coronavirus
treatment we can manage the patient's
through symptomatic care and supportive
care of course and many patients already
the Chinese have said have survived this
infection the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention have this top of
the mind they have deployed over a
hundred people to New York to San
Francisco and Los Angeles they will be
screening people who are arriving from
particularly Wuhan China to see whether
they are sick
so there are laboratories around the
world including our own National
Institutes of Health that are now
already working on developing a rapid
diagnostic test and the other thing
they're doing is starting to work on a
vaccine the global community is really
watching this with great care and we in
the United States definitely are on the
alert and ready to respond
[Music]